on the engineering side
maybe a dark question but do you think
it's possible to use these machine
learning methods to
start to engineer proteins
and the next question is uh something
quite a few biologists are against some
are for for study purposes is to
engineer viruses
do you think machine learning like
something like alpha fold could be used
to engineer viruses
so to answering the first question you
know it has been
you know a part of the
research in the protein science the
protein design
is you know is a very prominent
areas of research of course you know one
of the pioneers is david baker
and rosetta algorithm that you know
essentially
was doing the the nova design and was
used
to design new proteins you know and
designer proteins means design of
functions so like
when you design a protein you can
control i mean the whole point of a
protein
with the protein structure comes a
function like
correct it's doing something correct so
you can design
different things so you can yeah so you
can do well you can look at the proteins
from the function perspective you can
also look at the proteins from the
structure perspective right so the
structural building blocks
so if you want to have a building block
of a certain shape
you can try to achieve it yes by you
know introducing a new pro
program sequence and predicting you know
uh
how it will fold so uh
so with that i mean it's it's a natural
uh one of the you know natural uh
applications of these algorithms
uh now talking about engineering
a virus with machine learning with
machine learning right so so
well um you know so luckily for us
i mean uh we don't have that much
data right uh we actually
uh right now one of the projects that we
are carrying on in the
lab is we which we're trying to develop
a machine learning
algorithm that uh determines the uh
whether or not
the current strain is pathogenic and the
current strain of the cardiovirus
of the one of the virus i mean so so
there are applications to
coronaviruses because we have strains of
sars cover two also sarskovi
mers that are pathogenic but we also
have strains
of other coronaviruses that are you know
not
pathogenic i mean the the common cold uh
viruses
and uh you know and some other ones
right
so so pathogenic meaning spreading
pathogenic means actually inflicting
damage correct uh
there are also some you know seasonal
versus
pandemic strains of influenza right
and to determining the what are the
molecular determinant
right so that are built in into the
protein sequence into the
gene sequence right so and uh whether or
not the machine learning can
determine those those components
right oh interesting so like using
machine learning that's really
interesting to
to into given give the input
is like uh what the entire sequence the
protein sequence
and then determine if this thing is
going to be able to do damage
to to uh to a biological system yeah
so so i mean good machine learning
you're saying we don't have enough data
for that
we i mean for for this specific one we
do uh we might
actually okay you know have to back up
on this because we're still in the
process
there was uh one uh work uh that
appeared in by archive by eugene kunian
who is one of these you know uh pioneers
in in in
evolutionary genomics uh and they
tried to look at this uh but uh you know
the the methods were sort of
standard uh you know supervised learning
uh
methods uh and now the question is
you know can you you know advance it
further by by using you know not so
standard methods
you know so there's obviously a lot of
hope in in transfer learning
where you can actually try to transfer
the information that the
machine learns about the proper protein
sequences
right and uh you know so so there is
some promise in going this direction but
if we have this
it would be extremely useful because
then we could essentially forecast
the potential mutations that would make
a current
or less pathogenic and anticipate
dissipate them
from a vaccine development for the
treatment any viral drug development
that that would be a very crucial task
but
you could also use that system to then
say
how would we potentially modify this
virus
to make it more pathogenic this
that's true that's true i mean uh
you know the again
the hope is well several things right so
one
is that you know it's even if you design
a you know a sequence right
so to carry out the actual
experimental biology to ensure that
all the common components working you
know
is is a completely different matter
difficult process yes
uh then they did you know uh we've seen
in the past the there could be some
regulation of the
the moment the scientific community
recognizes that it's now
becoming no longer a sort of a a fun
puzzle to
you know for machine learning could be
available yeah so then there might be
some regulation so
i i think back in what 2015
there was you know the there was the
issue on regulating the
uh the research on um on influenza
strains right that there
were you know several groups uh you know
use surfaces
mutation analysis to to determine
whether or not this strain will jump
from one species to another and i think
there was like a
half a year more moratorium on on the
research on on the paper
published until you know uh scientists
you know analyzed it and decided that
it's actually safe
um i forgot what that's called something
a function testing function
function gain a function yeah and gain a
functional loss of function that's right
sorry
uh it's it's like let's watch this thing
mutate for a while
to see like to see what kind of things
we can observe
um i guess i'm not so much worried about
that kind of research if there's a lot
of regulation
and if it's done very well and with with
confidence and seriously
i am more worried about kind of this
uh you know the the the underlying
aspect of this question is more like 50
years from now
uh speaking to the drake equation one
one of the parameters in the drake
equation is how long civilizations last
and that's that seems to be the most
important value actually for calculating
if there's other alien
intelligence civilizations out there
that's where there's most variability
uh assuming like if life if that
percentage
that life can emerge is like not
zero like if we're super unique then
it's the
how long we last is basically the most
important thing
so from from a selfish perspective but
also from a drake
uh equation perspective i'm worried
about the la our civilization lasting
and you kind of think about all the ways
in which machine learning could be used
to design
greater weapons of destruction
right and i mean one way to ask
that if you look sort of 50 years from
now 100 years from now
would you be more worried about natural
pandemics
or engineered pandemics
like who's who is the better designer of
viruses
nature or humans if we look down the
line
i i think uh in my view i would still be
worried about the
natural pandemics simply because i mean
the
the capacity uh of
the nature producing yeah this it does a
pretty good job right
yes and the motivation for using virus
engineering viruses
for uh as a weapon is a weird one
because
uh maybe you can correct me on this but
it's very it seems very difficult to
target
a virus right the whole point of a
weapon the way a rocket works
if a starting point you have an end
point and you're trying to hit a target
to hit a target with a virus is very
difficult it's basically
just right it it's the target would be
the human species
oh man yeah i have a i have a hope in us
i'm
forever optimistic that we will not
there's no
there's insufficient evil in the world
to do to lead that to that kind of
destruction
well you know i also hope that i mean
that's what we see
i mean uh with the way we are getting
connected
the world is getting connected i think
it it helps
for the world to become more transparent
yeah so so the information spread
is you know i think it's one of the key
things for the for the society
to become more balanced yeah one way or
another this is something that people
disagree with me on but
i do think that uh the kind of secrecy
that governments have
so you're kind of speaking more to the
other aspects like
research community being more open
companies are being more open
government is still like
we're talking about like military
secrets yeah i think i think military
secrets
of the kind that could destroy the world
will become also a thing of the 20th
century
it'll become more and more open yeah
like i
i think nations will lose power in the
21st century like
lose sufficient power towards secrecies
transparency
is more beneficial than secrecy but of
course that's not obvious
let's hope so let's hope so that that
you know the
the the uh the governments
will become more transparent
you